I was wondering um for either of you
whether you could compare the French
attitude towards Muslim immigrants with
the attitude in the u.s. because it
seems like us destructive of Muslim
communities here is fueled more by a
fears of terrorism anything and that the
religious aspects are more aside
effective like it's not a direct assault
on like the veil or something like that
and so I was wondering why that might be
is it because I'm the US is generally a
more religious country and so is less
inclined to distrust religious practices
just because they are religious
practices or is there a certain
different organization of Muslim
communities here that makes them more
willing to integrate I suppose into
American communal life I mean I think
you know I dash kind of outlined that
you know the usual and also I think
correct answer to that question which is
has to do with the very different
political histories and therefore very
different political cultures of France
and the United States in particular the
dominance the predominance of particular
what i would call radical or secularists
republicanism you know with this origin
in the french revolution the u.s. also
has been deeply influenced by by
republicanism but it was a different
kind of republicanism more day istic
republicanism which never took the kind
of radically anti-clerical has been that
the French Revolution did and there has
always you know certainly from kind of
the early republic on increasingly a
kind of a less a fair liberalism which
which emerges which basically
understands religion is a form of self
as a you know as a right as sort of
falling into the rights of conscience
and as a form of self-expression and
that's been reinforced historically of
course through the arrival absorption of
an emergence of more and more more and
more religious groups you answer the
other question though about and I don't
know maybe I assure is going to disagree
with me about this I don't think that
you can you you can pull apart the
headscarf
eight and nine eleven and other you know
other other encounters like that so for
example one of my students last year
wrote a thesis on British and French
discourse around the headscarf debate
and there is a remarkable shift within
Britain after nine eleven away from
multiculturalism and towards something
actually that increasingly looks like
like French Republican at them and a
similar shift can be seen in the
Netherlands oh there that they're kind
of the catalyst for that is the tailfin
cult murder but you know similar similar
kind of backlash